L, glutamine powder. Why is it not good for cancer patients? Because glutamine can be a direct
fuel source for cancer. So not with everybody, but glutamine can be a direct fuel source of
for cancer glutamated, glutamated, ethylidine. So I write a lot about that in my book. So it's a big
no-no. You're going to you need glutamine, you need glutamine to make glutamate, which is an
excitatory neurotransmitter to your brain. So don't get me, don't get wrong that it is an
essential amino acid in your body, but take a not exogenous glutamine for somebody as a
history of cancer. It's just done right foolishness. So you do not take glutamine. Why do you give a
person? Why would anybody? Why would a functional doctor recommend glutamine? That's typically
recommended with somebody who has gut issues, and if they have a damaged gut, leaky gut,
syndrome, take olglotamine. It's great because it'll help your cells really reproduce quickly,
and you can help heal your gut. You know, real nice. Why? Because olglotamine is a really strong
feeder, especially for epithelial cells, and you'll reproduce cells quite quickly. Why would you
want to do that if you had a headache kind of history of cancer? Very dangerous. I know
functional medicine doctors that have no idea what they're doing with cancer, and they'll recommend
olglotamine for somebody because, oh, well, we got to heal the gut. Everything begins in the gut.
Do you have cancer? We need to heal the gut. Absolute idiocy in my part. So do not do that.
But I'll tell you what I'm saying. Practitioner should know better.